i want to talk about a really good remedy for
angina as well as any type of irregular heartbeat
and this natural remedy would be a good thing
to keep around someone with pre-existing heart
problems heart failure past heart attacks
especially if you're flying on a plane
keep it with you and the remedy is called
hawthorne berry extract it's been used for a very
long time for all sorts of circulatory problems as
well as respiratory illness specifically irregular
heartbeats hypertension chest pain harding of
the arteries as well as other symptoms related to
heart failure like difficulty breathing as well as
fatigue but today it's primarily used for angina
that's chest pain because it increases blood flow
and it helps to restore a normal heartbeat there's
quite a bit of research on this natural remedy
demonstrating significant improvements in heart
function increased ability to exercise after
someone had heart failure it was found to be just
as effective as the medication captopril which is
for heart conditions and there's also improvements
in shortness of breath and fatigue now how does
it create these very cool effects well there are
certain phytonutrients in this natural uh
plant that helps dilate the blood vessels
increasing blood flow as well as protecting
the inside the vessel from oxidation
and free radical damage now before taking
this remedy or any remedies to replace your
medication check with your doctor first i'm not
recommending this is going to cure your heart or
replace any medicine now the two compounds
they isolated that create the most effect
are number one pro anthocyanins as well as the
bioflavonoids these two natural compounds have
a very specific effect of relaxing the coronary
artery which is many times involved in a heart
attack because it can go into a spasm and so this
is why i say that this would be a good thing to
take if you're traveling if you're on a plane
if you're out and about keep some in your pocket
just in case hey before you go if
you're benefiting from any of my content
i would love to hear about your success
story please share it in the link down below